meine damen und herren sie haben sie ihr
seid heute morgen live informiert und
dabei auch viele reaktionen aus den
parteien schon gezeigt eine frage ist
dabei hält zentral welche politischen
hintergründe dieser tat hat der europa
staatsminister rot wenn der spd der
gegen die afd direkt an und sagte die
partei war der politische arm des
rechtsterrorismus demokratie verachtung
rassismus antisemitismus und
islamfeindlichkeit fielen bei der afg
auf fruchtbaren boden
der parteichef wollten hier dagegen sagt
das ist weder eine rechte noch eine
linke terror tat ist sei vielmehr die
wahnhafte tat eines irren und die afg
fraktionschefin weide sprach von einem
schrecklichen vorfall sie äußerte
mitgefühl gegenüber den opfern ganz
aktuell hat sich jetzt auch ihr co
fraktionsvorsitzender alexander gauland
geäußert es fehlen die worte was soll
man dazu sagen es ist ein fürchterliches
verbrechen geschehen und alles was man
hört kann man nur sagen wir fühlen mit
den angehörigen die ich menschen
verloren haben
es ist unfassbar dass so was geschieht
und mehr kann man dazu eigentlich nicht
sagen
karrenbauer sagen da solche taten in ein
paar wichtigen rechtlichen hinweis dafür
dass auch die ag verantwortlich ist
erfahren das ist erstens unsinn und
zweitens finde ich es schäbig
ich hab das von frau kramp karrenbauer
und helmut gelesen ich finde es schäbig
so eine furchtbare tat zu
instrumentalisieren alles was wir wissen
ist dass das ein völlig geistes
verwirrter mensch ist er hat ja auch
über amerika und irgendwelche
vergewaltigungsszenen paraphrasiert von
daher finde ich es ich sage es nochmal
schäbig wenn so etwas instrumentalisiert
wird um gegen politische konkurrenten
vorzugehen
thailand ist es ja nicht nur frau kramp
karrenbauer auch herr court hat heute
gesagt dass ihre reden im bunde
er hat glaube ich gesagt humus sind für
solche taten und des mannes sind der
worte auch gefallen als ihrer fraktion
von messer männer und kopftuchmädchen
die ordnung das hat das damit zu tun
entschuldigung
hier handelt es sich um einen verwirrten
menschen der wahrscheinlich diese reden
von denen sie gerade sprechen noch nicht
einmal gehört hat was soll das also was
sollen da verbindungen die gar nichts
damit zu tun haben ich kann nun mal in
einen menschen nicht reingucken ich
frage mich auch weshalb er nicht
offensichtlich hat er ja irgendwelche
leute angezeigt weil sie ihn verfolgt
haben das heißt das muss ja schon
auffällig gewesen sein
das hat bestimmt nichts mit bundestags
reden zu tun
das hat nichts mit mit verharmlosung zu
tun wenn ich mir die statements angucke
oder anhöre die er von sich gegeben hat
dann ist es ein völlig geistig
verwirrter mensch da kann ich doch nicht
in irgendeiner weise darüber rechten und
sagen ja das ist aber politisch
motiviert im moment ist es ein kranker
ein irrer die nicht in dieser
gesellschaft frei herumlaufen sollte da
haben sie völlig recht
der generalbundesanwalt hat er
gesprochen von zutiefst rassistischen
motiv warum nimmt die afg eigentlich das
wort rassismus
das kann schon sein dass es ein zutiefst
rassistische motive ist ich habe da gar
nichts zu erwidern
das kann sein aber es folgt
offensichtlich einer völlig krank
geisteshaltung und mit wem wir sehen was
die motive sind ich habe das von
generalbundesanwalt gelesen warum soll
ich das nicht in den mund nehmen
bei jemandem rassismus in der form ist
natürlich auch geisteskrank ist doch
völlig klar
weil das auch gerade einen großen stein
meisten wieder klicken sie mit der sorge
auch auf
er sprach im internet und niemand könnte
es auch sein dass solche doch mit man
sich rechtsextremen straftaten im
internet geplant werden und dann in die
tat umgesetzt werden
das kann so sein das kann ich gar nicht
bestreiten alle die mich kennen wissen
dass ich mich in dem bereich überhaupt
nicht aufhalte
aber ja es gibt eine frohe es gibt
leider eine verrohung unserer
gesellschaft bei der das netz heute halt
nur ausdruck ist denken sie an die
angriffe auf polizisten auf helfer bei
unfällen
wir müssen uns in der tat alle überlegen
ob unsere gesellschaft noch eine humane
gesellschaft ist da haben sie völlig
recht
nur man soll nicht alles durcheinander
bringen die verrohung der gesellschaft
ist das eine wenn es um eine kranke
person geht ist das etwas anderes
denn der folgt anderen uns unbekannten
antrieben und nicht jetzt sagen wir mal
der führungen netz ich glaube das sind
zwei verschiedene paar schuhe die man
nicht verlängern sollte